foreign
hey folks welcome back to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream
157q and a segment we are ready to go
we've got uh we got a cat and we've got
a spare cat no
they got two cats and we need two more
spares Ah that's probably true yeah yep
all right we are going to do what I
always forget to say in the in the first
hour start with a question from the
Discord server this week which they
choose and send to us and I had been
hoping having received this this morning
to look into it a little bit and I
didn't have time so we're gonna riff
somewhat uninformedly oh wow working
with internet
she never shows yeah yeah
question from the Discord about the
safety of stevia
WebMD says that the FDA has only
improved approved the purified form
stevioside as safe WebMD concludes quote
if you see whole Stevia leaves or crude
Stevia extracts at your local natural
food store don't buy them
but the article also says that people in
South America and Asia have been using
the leaves for many years any thoughts
love you guys
um so I wanted to just find a good
history of um of the use and I had just
pulled up an article published in 2010
in the international Journal of food
sciences and nutrition
called Stevia Stevia rabadiana which is
the scientific name a bio sweetener a
review
but the abstract is weird enough no not
the abstract the introduction
um talking about how it's
um
in widespread cultivation in several
Indian States but I know separately that
it's a it's a neotropical plant it's it
doesn't grow in the Paleo Tropics
yeah it's per it's in the in in Paraguay
and Brazil is where it grows I love the
family uh Astor asterisky so daisies
again right pastors or daisies I don't
know I don't know I'm gonna look that up
because that's what we need to know that
is what we need to know right yeah
except my computer is saying no you
don't
never mind I can't believe this
the number of crashes this machine has
experienced
um lately is remarkable
um yeah it's gigantic so asteracy is
also
um
yeah uh composite a 32 000 known species
of flowering plants including yes
daisies Masters sunflowers the whole
thing basically most of the things you
can think of is really symmetric at the
flower level
Stevia is a
it's not a tree
Woody shrub that can reach 80
centimeters in height when it is fully
matured so you know two feet-ish uh the
stevia genus comprises at least 110
species but there may be as many as 300
it's Habitat oh it's Habitat extends
from the southwestern United States the
Brazilian Highlands I think it's mostly
out of Brazil and Paraguay though the uh
guarani people have been using it uh
sort of as a sweetener and maybe even
medicinally for a long time
and when you initially uh
uh began literally just reading this you
were talking about populations that have
a history of using beliefs who are they
the intro the guarani as I just said
right that's the only population you
mentioned yeah well the reason I'm not
sure that this first uh you know
scientific paper that I have come up
with is the best source here even though
it's a you know it's a review
um well I guess they're so
the authors are Indian the authors are
working out of India so that may be why
in the introduction there's a sentence
about the successful cultivation in
recent years in many areas of the Indian
states of Rajasthan
Maharashtra karela and erisa so
otherwise otherwise that sentence is
like why why are we focused there that's
confusing it seems like it's pan
tropical in distribution when it's not
but I think actually having just
realized that the authors are Indian
that's probably why okay and you know
they're yeah I think we know enough to
respond basically yes now we do yes
um I mean I'm learning this as I'm
talk to you guys
um
I guess
oh people in Japan have been using it
um people in Japan have been using it
for how long
are we talking a modern phenomenon
because that's really what this hinge is
hard to tell um I mean it's it's just it
doesn't grow there so it's it's
relatively use of
um
yeah they're I see the papers I want to
find but I don't have time to do that so
um
oh it is medicinally used in Brazil and
Paraguay
um as a natural control for diabetes
because it tastes sweet but it doesn't I
don't remember exactly what it doesn't
do but it doesn't your body doesn't
regard it as sugar so it doesn't process
it but you don't metabolize it as a
sugar um and apparently it's also got
like a bitter there's a bitter note
um that is the thing that most people
will recognize
um if you just try to replace Stevia or
sugar with stevia yeah so the bitter
note uh indicates possible toxicity it
is very unusual for a plant to be able
to create the sensation of sweetness
without providing sugar because we are
attuned to That Trick
after many millions of years of
evolution
so the question is
it sounds like we've got a common uh
uh scientific nonsense reversal of the
precautionary principle by WebMD yeah of
course that's what they always do they
are going to argue that the pure version
is safe and don't touch anything that
isn't because of course how can they say
you know if you've got some complex
plant that has many compounds and they
haven't studied them so what they're
going to tell you is avoid that well I
mean also it's leaves right so you know
the plant doesn't want you eating it
right it's not like it's a fruit and um
you know maybe it's not the intended
disperser but you know it is it was
created by the plant to be eaten whereas
leaves no plant makes leaves in order to
be eaten well I do want to know why this
plant is putting out a signal yeah
assuming it's a secondary
compound it's putting out a signal that
many creatures will take to be an
indication of value so there's a
question mark there but yeah nothing of
the natural history in this the basic
question hinges on the following
you've got a population with a
long-standing relationship with this
plant
do they consume it if they're consuming
it just as a medicine which it sounds
like they're not but if they're
consuming it just as a medicine then
that doesn't tell you that it's safe
because medicines are toxins that are
titrated in order to make a benefit in
the case of somebody who has a defect
mostly it's a dietary additive rather
than medicine I think in many places
where it's being used right I'm not
talking about where it's being used I'm
talking about the only indication that
we would have about safety would be that
there's somebody with a long-standing
history
and so a population that is a
long-standing history
the question is are they using it as a
medicine are they using it in some other
capacity
because we could infer something about
safety from that if they're using it as
a medicine then it may be that they have
protocols and that is protecting us from
they're protecting them from toxicity
and that we are borrowing it for some
purpose that has not been established to
be safe by uh the long-standing use of
it I've got one little bit here
the traditional method of use by the
paraguayan guarani Indians was to dry
the leaves and to use them to sweeten
tea in medicine so to chew the leaves as
a sweet treat
Stevia was regularly used in drinks many
times a day not just occasionally with
no side effects okay so the use of dried
leaves etc etc so and this is a study
from 1991 that is looking
um I don't have a study in front of me
but the title of it is
well I was hoping it was going to be an
anthropological study uh it's not it's
in chemical abstracts effective
technological procedures and the
composition of volatile substances and
Stevia revadiana but it sounds like they
did a little bit of
anthropological looking as well so if
it's true that this was used in a
general way
that did not have to do with medicinal
use then they are using it safely almost
certainly
that does not mean that it is safe for
others you could have for example you
know populations differ in how good they
are at breaking down lactose sugars they
vary and how good they are at breaking
down alcohol right and so it could be
that this population has a long enough
standing history or that populations in
this part of the world in general have
some ability to metabolize something
that others don't
so it's not perfectly safe but I would
say the chances that if these folks have
a long-standing relationship with it
that it is safe to consume in moderation
even in its not pure form is pretty high
yeah
um and so I have a claim here
um that
um the guarani have been using it for at
least many hundreds of years
as a sweetener yeah so that seems a
little short but it may be that that's
only as far back as they could ascertain
yeah
um that they were using it but
uh anyway I would say uh if I had to
guess chances are pretty good that it's
safe and chances are pretty good that it
means nothing that the safety of the
purified form has been established
because for one thing what they almost
certainly did not do is look into the
long-term effect of the things so their
whole sense that it's safe is about them
having looked for a kind of danger and
apparently not found it and undoubtedly
in order to make the experiment
um easier they use the purified form
because they knew exactly what they were
studying but basically I would say they
are giving you a warning based on not
having information about something that
you can infer based on other evidence
which is a long-standing relationship
between a population and this plant and
not at a medicinal level yeah I guess I
would just I would add
the long-standing relationship with the
people who live where this plant grows
natively and there use of it in their
diet on an apparently very regular basis
suggests
relative safety with two caveats I would
say the one that you've made which is
that like lacking alcohol
like lacking alcohol dehydrogenase in
East Asian populations
makes alcohol a trickier situation for
people from those populations there
might be some specific adaptation to you
know taking apart something in Stevia
that the rest of us don't have yeah
that's one thing
neither of us have any idea if that's
true I don't know and then the other
thing is just uh you know a caution
about
something that tricks the system so
extraordinarily and is you know so much
sweeter I now I've taken it down but
it's like you know 10 to 20 times this
is we're talking an order of magnitude
and higher level of sweetness and I
don't know what the measure of sweetness
is but uh you know sugar isn't good for
us
and uh We've you know humans have eaten
a lot of fruit over the years and so you
know we we know what sweet is and and
you know and honey too and and we pursue
it so I am I am skeptical of any
artificial sweeteners less so of ones
um that are growing in a place where the
people who live there have been using it
for hundreds of years but still there's
something in me that says what you know
what is that trick of the you know of
the palette
doing exactly and what other
consequences might there be especially
if there's a bitter note right which
tends to be a proxy for a toxin of some
kind right
um I would add another caveat which is
um you will of course have no idea when
this is mass produced in what way it's
mass produced and what you may be
encountering in in terms of the
distillation process or right exactly
you don't know well yeah now it's being
grown in you know states in India where
are they applying yeah are they applying
lots of agrochemicals to the fields and
that's not what you're taking in who
knows what they're doing and there's
also the concentration issue right it
may be that the plants themselves like
as with uh coca leaves and cocaine that
the leaves themselves are benign but if
you start concentrating the stuff then
you create a hazard so there's all kinds
of stuff to wonder about but the general
question are the leaves themselves safe
probably given that these people have
been using it
um but you do want to know that that
work is high quality and that this
really is a long-standing relationship
and that yeah they really are using it
to sweeten drinks right so they're
getting it they're getting a dose of
it's not that they're it's not purely
medicinal where a toxin would be
expected right well people were put up
with with
um side effects yeah in a way that
choosing to go back multiple times a day
maybe to have a pleasurable experience
and a drink
um you you don't you don't bring that
along with a an obvious discomfort yeah
good
all right the I've now opened up a bunch
of pages on Asters and Stevia and have
to find
are
questions where are they there we go all
right hello come on up welcome and he's
stepping on the computer okay
um
first question from darker
submissions.com today
do you think there is a way
either through biological procedures or
statistical studies to determine
conclusively if a cardiac or heart event
or cardiac or heart events in the
aggregate are related to the vaccine
also how are we able to distinguish
vaccine harm from an actual covet harm
these distinctions seem like they'd be
helpful to settle some of the fighting
finally do your instincts tell you we
will eventually turn the corner and go
back to relative normal
um I wish my instincts told me that yeah
these things tell me the opposite yeah
on the last question at the moment I
don't think we're going back to normal
unfortunately now maybe this is an
Adaptive Valley and we establish a new
normal on the basis that we've just
learned how much danger we're in because
our institutions all suck that would be
great
um
from the point of view of
was the question about autopsies or was
the question in living people it doesn't
say it do you think there's a way either
through biological procedures or
statistical studies to determine
conclusively if a cardiac or heart event
or cardiac or heart events in the
aggregate are related to the vaccine how
can we distinguish vaccine harm from
actual covet harm yes there are several
different ways
one
you've got the distinction between uh
2020
and 2021 and Beyond which tells us a lot
about that distinction to the extent
that you can look at the data that
distinguishes the events so that's the
statistical that's the aggregate
um I have wondered this question about
individual events a lot and I gather
that there are some I do not know the
specifics but I think Dr McCullough has
argued that myocarditis looks different
from covid versus the vaccines and I
don't I don't know the specifics I don't
that is the only one of these though
that I have heard that someone who knows
his stuff and has looked carefully is
saying actually it manifests differently
the the the the the way that clinically
we can tell so if we're looking
there's a lot of work that has to be
done and unfortunately
we are the work that is being done is
being done in an environment that is not
conducive to Discovery because there are
so many dogs that people have in the
fight that you know they want to elevate
the harm of covid so that the harm of
the inoculations is uh drowned out for
example so that's a perverse incentive
I think the key thing to understand
is that you have one set of harms that
actually does not inherently distinguish
between
the shots and the disease spike is
produced by the shots and the disease
and to the extent that spike is bad you
can get inflammation as a result of
spikes circulating in the bloodstream
okay that is very different
then the invasion of heart cells that
then go on to be destroyed by T cells
right and so to the extent that what we
are seeing are people who have had their
hearts and by the way it won't just be
their hearts
we call it myocarditis in the heart but
the destruction of tissue when cells are
invaded by the MRNA and then destroyed
by the immune system that will happen in
all tissues but
cells can obviously be invaded by SARS
cov2
it doesn't have to be the question is do
they and this was the point I was trying
to some degree right there's myocarditis
associated with covet as well right but
myocarditis means inflammation
okay that's not I'm not saying that SARS
Kobe 2 doesn't ever invade a heart cell
but there's actually little reason for
it to and so my guess is since we're not
talking about a completely synthetic
virus we're talking about something that
was taken from the wild and enhanced
right I think the chances are low that
it invades the heart liberally because
it has no reason to do it it doesn't
help it spread and actually it gets in
the way of it spreading so
the
um the the confusion here is that
myocarditis is not a specific disease it
is a symptom it is a symptom of a couple
different things it could be a symptom
of irritation or slight damage and it
lumps mechanisms right and so the point
what is special about the MRNA shots in
particular is that they are
indiscriminate in terms of what they get
into not even the DNA shots are
indiscriminate because the DNA shots
utilize this adenovirus and the
adenovirus has its own preferences about
what cells to invade and invading the
heart is not likely to be useful to it
so so the point is look
maybe there's myocarditis with covid
alone right but that just means
inflammation the damage that is signaled
by the inflammation in the heart is
um
largely associated with the MRNA shots
and the hypothesis not just mine several
other people have come up with related
versions of this hypothesis but the
hypothesis is that the mrnas get into
cells indiscriminately because they're
just covered in a fat that has an
affinity for cells and it gets into them
that's how it's designed to work right
and the only limitation on where it does
that comes from the locality of the shot
and we know that that doesn't keep it
from flowing around whether that's
because of an aspiration issue or
because they just naturally leak into
the body
or both and so the damage from the MRNA
shots that are getting into heart cells
into myocytes and causing those cells to
be destroyed those cells then unlike
other tissues of the body not every
other tissue but unlike almost all of
the tissues of the body the heart does
not heal right it's scars and so you
there is presumably a particular danger
in the phase where you have effectively
an open wound on the inside of your
heart in the vasculature right that
wound is a particular vulnerability you
will be better off after it scars is
this diagnosable in some
um and hold on this is true for the
entire all cardiovascular vessels all
circulatory vessels right they do not
heal they scar which means at um so the
whatever we were calling this the stuff
at the beginning one of the symptoms
that people were talking about foreign
[Music]
well whatever
um that that may precisely be about the
circulatory vessels at the capillary
level where it's you know one red blood
cell wide uh
having scarred as a result of of the the
virus and then you know becoming not
um you know not I want to say conducive
to flow infusible defusable something
profusable profusable
um I think that's I think that's
slightly different
um because what we know is that Spike
causes the
um clumping of blood cells
Spike itself so that doesn't necessarily
require scarring now that it doesn't it
doesn't require it right yep there is
vulnerability of all of the circulatory
vessels to being invaded by the MRNA and
then once invaded they presumably
transcribe the spike protein and they
get attacked by T cells that view them
as infected
so the question is is there a way to be
sure yeah I think on autopsy there is a
way to be
Almost sure
right in other words on autopsy and
maybe this can be done with a
sophisticated scan like a CAT scan one
can view that there is damage my
understanding from people who have
looked deeply into this issue is that
there's something akin to third degree
burns on the inside of the heart right
now those burns are unlikely to be due
to anything else
and the fact of them being the result of
this can be diagnosed if you don't get
there too late
right if the event happens you get this
wound from the vaccination the most
likely time for you to suffer a cardiac
arrest is presumably soon right and the
longer you make it the longer you're
likely to make it I would love to hear a
cardiologist evaluate that but in terms
of just the basic biology of the system
that's what you would expect the wound
is more dangerous than the scar the scar
is less useful than the original tissue
but
um but the point is you will be at some
intermediate phase where you will have
cells that have been destroyed and
eliminated and are just gone right I
mean imagine you had a burn some cells
are just completely destroyed some cells
are hanging out on the edge
and so the question is is there a
concentration of an indicator of uh
these cells having been producing Spike
protein in the form of some cells that
are there having Spike on their surface
and this sort of thing
so from the point of view of nailing it
down that's a guess as to how you would
do it
somebody who understands Cardiology well
should evaluate that and fine tune it
and or maybe it's wrong and then that
person should tell us how you would do
it but yes I believe an autopsy can do
it short of an autopsy you know you
don't exactly want to go biopsying the
heart
right that's a danger in itself yeah
but I do believe you could certainly
with
autopsies get a bead on what the
pathology looks like and how frequently
it is the result of a a vaccine injury
and then in living people you could
infer well it is beginning to happen
there's there's this big German data set
um which uh is quite alarming anyway you
can look at Dr Malone's
um sub stack which points to this German
study but there it is beginning to come
out now we are seeing some autopsy stuff
but yes for a long time they were
avoiding doing autopsies I think because
they didn't want to know well and I mean
this is this is one of the core
questions right that we've been asked
here and everyone who's thinking about
this should want to know the answer
because
you know
healthy young men collapse on the field
and
um you know we don't know
and there's all sorts of speculation but
when we know that we're not being told
enough even to ask the right questions
about what's happening like
oh
the only thing we have for sure
other than possibly the kinds of stuff
that you're talking about developing
here is 2020 versus 2021 and later with
regard to
deaths associated with code-like stuff
but we know that dying with and dying of
has been conflated and we also know that
the evolution of the virus has done all
sorts of weird and wacky things and you
know Omicron was less likely to kill you
out right uh than what was circulating
in 2020 and maybe whatever the crazy one
is called now x dot one whatever it is
is
is less yet but you know maybe longer
term it's got more risk like we don't
know the answers to any of these
questions and until and unless
we actually do some ones start
developing exactly these sorts of ways
to distinguish between you know once
that vaccine was that covered this the
true story will never be told because
the you know to the degree that there
are data that are takeable and then
analyzable forever once you have the
data you can analyze them if they were
taken well you know infinitely but the
ability to access the data will
disappear they are disappearing if
they're not being taken they're
disappearing and then oh sorry guys I
guess it's our version of the story
because you don't have another one yeah
it it uh Harkens back to the discussion
we were having in the main podcast where
you know none of this is all that hard
to do right if you want to find out
whether these inoculations are having
this effect you can study it there's no
mystery about how you would do this yeah
um and what we are frustratingly
Downstream of is the obligation that we
embarrass the system into functioning
right that we embarrass it that we ask
so many questions about people Keeling
over on uh this field or that field and
that we you know insist on autopsies and
that we require the press to report
these things
and it just shouldn't be this way the
point is the system has become an
obstacle to understanding it claims to
be the source of understanding it has
become an obstacle to understanding
because it has higher priorities and
it's not supposed to yeah
that's right
next question totally different
from my casual observations it appears
that when women are younger they are
attracted much more to the alpha male
type EG bad boy and as women get older
they are attracted to Beta types could
this be related to fertility levels
where young women who are most fertile
seek Alphas but as women's fertility
diminishes the Banning strategy shifts
to betas who are more likely to stay
around thanks guys keep up the great
work
I don't agree with the framing of Alpha
and beta here yeah it's uh it's a sort
of common it's a common way to frame
human males but this isn't right and it
also misunderstand I mean alpha alpha
and beta are kind of archaic ways of
describing dominance hierarchies in
non-human animals as well but it is you
know it can be accurate there are there
are organisms with linear dominance
hierarchies by sex of course and um you
know we all know that Alpha's the first
letter and beta is the next and you know
on and on
and so it's a decent shorthand even
though it's not really a set of terms
that is used in animal behavior at this
point but what is widely missed is that
alpha males in species that are really
clearly uh organisms with linear male
hierarchies which it's not clear that
most cultures of humans are but you know
there's definitely dominance
are actually the most likely to be
conciliatory they're the they're the
peacemakers like the the alphas and you
know if you in I've always mispronounce
his name it's like Franz Duval the um
the primatologist who wrote among other
things peacemaking among primates has a
a career of thinking about of of
watching admittedly most of mostly
captive great apes and looking
specifically at at dominance and
dominance interactions
um between both within both sexes and
between Sexes and time and again what he
finds is that in sort of a ranking not
of the individuals in terms of their
dominance but in terms of
um their conciliatory Tendencies and
prowess like who who tends to be the
most the biggest Peacemaker the alpha
male is always on top and then if you're
talking about a species with linear
hierarchies in males and females like
alpha male alpha female and then you
know most of the other females and then
the rest of the males yeah they're not
really into peacemaking because they're
trying to become Alpha right
um but actually to be alpha is to is to
to be thinking about the whole group
because otherwise you're not going to
stay on top very long
um I would also
there's another reason to just doubt
this interpretation right if we're
talking about human beings and the
question was specifically about human
beings
um yep the stakes in reproduction are so
high and the
variability in the value of Mates is yes
maybe somewhat in endogenous
characteristics but it is also
tremendously tied up in resource
availability dedication and loyalty
ability to protect and so the point is
the idea that young women are more
fertile and therefore seeking higher
status males
a males I mean I either a male is
infertile
or he's fertile enough right to produce
right Offspring and so the point is
really a
a female who prioritized the let's say
let's substitute the term virility of a
male because she was very fertile young
right what is she doing right the point
is really what she wants it's not a
shortage of sperm right it's not it's
not hard to come by and so the
um
a female does so a female reproductive
value is something that is greatest
early in life because the amount of
reproductive potential that lies in the
future rather than the past is greatest
on the cusp of reproduction right so
um
the pattern you're describing if it
exists
is liable to be that
um you have status in males and females
and that females who pair off early
are liable to be higher status have
access to a wider range of males and as
the population of available males
dwindles to ones that are less desirable
because of their inherited status
because of the resources they've
accumulated because of their physical
ability to protect all of the
characteristics that make for a
desirable mate right the point is the
later a female pairs off the farther
down the list in the male hierarchy that
female is likely to be and with
the very large caveat that in sort of
an easy divorce culture there's lots of
people constantly being thrown back into
the mating pool well and that is what I
was gonna end with here and I agree with
you divorce is a key feature but it's
like look you've got a dozen features
interesting just easy breakup culture
right easy breakup sex that doesn't
produce Offspring with any significant
regularity you've got all of these
factors and so you're trying to do
primatology on oh those two are you know
engaging in reproductive Behavior what
does that mean well maybe it means
nothing right because maybe the stakes
are really low and they've both thought
about it and thought Oh the stakes are
really low what the hell right so the
point is you can't infer very much from
preference if preference just means he's
kind of cute you know because the point
is it's only when the stakes are high
that these preferences truly reveal the
pattern that you're looking for which is
what is the bias in the human female and
the bias in the human male so I'm
recalling your
one of your figures from your
dissertation the trade-offs and the
efficient Frontier and you're basically
saying that in most modern mating and
dating games we're nowhere close to the
efficient Frontier so you can't do this
kind of analysis with this at least at
least with this level of detail yeah
we're nowhere close to the efficient
Frontier and we have all of these
garbage inputs right where you know we
are being sold a bill of goods with
respect to what sexual and mating
sophistication looks like right and the
point is it has taken all of the logic
out of the system and I'm not saying
that the logic was up to date or Fair it
wasn't but there's now none right it's
just uh it's chaos and so uh you know
the basic rule take it out of the realm
of mating and dating
the basic rule is do not
you've got the ability to point adaptive
tools for evaluating behaviors in any
creature at any time up until you get to
the present and the point is you can't
evaluate the present with those tools
because what you don't know is that the
pattern stands the test of time right at
the point that a pattern has stood the
test of time for a thousand years right
then you can say oh that's probably
adaptive I wonder why they do that to
the extent that it has lasted all of 17
minutes you don't know that's probably
just noise
mm-hmm
problems everywhere but who is
organizing Solutions we are our biggest
problems that our systems have been
corrupted will you discuss this with us
signed the rationalist Society of
problem solvers and they provided text
number
I think I know who this is okay so
um both of our websites have uh email
addresses on them go to go to maybe both
of them and send us both an email and
tell us you know a little bit more than
that before uh I mean I don't I don't
like to see my phone at all but I I
definitely don't um
like to randomly send my phone number
out into the universe right right that
that can be bad
um I will say don't take this the wrong
way I love rationalists but I worry
about them because their philosophy
seems to be so darn irrational so this
might be a convergent evolution
fire could be repeatedly discovered by
accident from lightning or from striking
rocks to make sparks but how did our
ancient ancestors first discover the
value of cooking food
I mean I think I think it's likely to
have been the same the same thing right
you walk through a scarred landscape
a fire scarred landscape and there's um
there's cooked meat around elk bunnies
squirrel like what you know whatever
couldn't get out of the way the fire as
it's still sort of smoking and sizzling
and all the vegetation is black and
there's you know
there's barbecued bunnies yep no I uh I
think this is this is almost certainly
thought of fire you know
barbecued bunny slamming fur yeah
um yeah no I
I this is what we discussed weeks ago
the difference between an evolutionary
puzzle
where there's a adaptive Valley between
this and the next opportunity or versus
a gentle slope and we've talked about
the fact that uh the creatures that are
sea creatures
venturing a little farther onto land
because the Meander line has left debris
that's edible the farther Inland you can
go the more there is to eat there's no
Gap right you don't have to get across
something it's just better and better
the more tolerant you are to move my
take on that conversation is the exact
opposite and I've got an entire lecture
on all the things you have to do to make
the move on to land that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying that the uh reward for
overcoming those obstacles is continuous
right but it's discreet with regard to
are you breathing air or water are you
supporting your way to your weight on
land or water no are is the you know is
the refractive index of air or water uh
what your eye is attuned to right I mean
are you Mo are you able to smell no not
really because you've been in water and
now there might be a reason to be able
to smell on land you know there's just
so so I'm not I mean obviously getting
onto land I do have a neck yes yeah
tetrapy exactly
um the I'm not disagreeing with you that
there are a tremendous number of
difficult problems to solve what I'm
arguing is that the creature that gets
one inch further than their competitors
has unlocked resource so the point is
the signal keep coming this way is
continuous rather than for example a
creature that is going from a big pool
temporarily into a small pool and back
again over some piece of rock right
where the point is there's no reward for
getting onto the rock you have to get
all the way to the pool before it's
there so anyway
um the
fire fire
so the the
um you've got a
creature that is involved in hunting and
Gathering and occasionally encounters
the aftermath of fire and the point is
the reward for
discovering resources you know will a
hunter have discovered a
a damaged but not dead animal
right and a animal will watch an animal
die in front of it right so the point is
there is a signal leading directly to
the discovery
of uh
cooked meat and there's a set of
detectors that one has that presumably
monitor the value of something that you
have eaten and so on and cooked meat
brings more more caloric value yeah you
get more you get more not nutrients but
calories
out of cooked meat and for our
hunter-gatherer ancestors that was
important they were limiting yeah that
was quite critical but I don't I don't
know about the stumbling upon a half
dead but burned enough to be cooked
animal well um scenario but uh I do it
does feel like probably as hard as this
is to imagine
for us now probably those first tastes
of cooked meat were less palatable than
eating raw meat because it was new yeah
uh you know even even though it turns
out to be good for us
uh it was it was novel and therefore
probably it was at least uh on
not preferred
and so the idea of cooked meat becoming
having to become a preferred taste is
itself sort of interesting yeah over
over evolutionary time well you would
imagine you know there's
the sort of circuit applies to a bunch
of things right
um including mating preferences right
when people are in very depoporate
circumstances they contemplate mates
they never would otherwise
but in food space you know how many
different levels of starving have human
ancestors experienced all of them right
up to the point that yukila over dead
because you don't have enough to eat
right and so the point is at what level
of starving do you first entertain the
possibility of consuming meat that is
not in the form that you're used to that
you're used to yeah right and yeah no
and I mean there's more caloric value
but also less likely to make you sick
less likely to be in you know infected
with you know prions or
maggots or anything else right maggots
wouldn't be the case unless you were
eating from already dead meat but yep
yeah
all right next question
have you heard of Boris and William
James Sidis s-i-d-i-s
I have not I don't think so yeah
um
let's see have you found any solid
studies about the negative efficacy of
the Vex have you read the recent one
from Cleveland Clinic John Campbell
removed his video about it love you guys
so this is going to be the the one that
we were asked about last week that I
couldn't find I've not gone and looked
at it uh yeah I have a d there yeah
um
yeah negative efficacy well did it say
efficacy yep negative efficacy negative
efficacy
uh appears to be a real phenomenon
that is to say there are at least cases
in which it seems to induce
vulnerability which could be antibody
dependent enhancement it could be
attenuation it could be original
antigenic sin I think it is still early
the fact is a system that worked would
be obsessed with discovering this
because it would actually have been
concerned in the first place about the
disease being passed on and avoiding
negative efficacy would be a key
but somehow we're still pretending
we collectively yeah
um
The opportunistic Outsider that you're
talking about is exactly who social
media enables and why social media is so
harmful it gives a voice to this that
was a box that should not have been
opened that's interesting that's
emerging from our conversation last in
the first in the first couple of hours
and it does it not just enables but it
uh
empowers empowers yeah and it it
such people win
by staying within their own framework
and uh unfortunately by dragging us into
theirs largely yeah well uh I mean we've
had a battle uh amongst
thinking people who are trying to
imagine what good moderation on social
media would look like yeah and one of
the key facets of that has been what to
think about anonymity and I must say
initially my sense as an evolutionary
biologist is
anonymity is new
it is wildly Amplified in its power on
social media we would be better off
without it now I got a lot of pushback
amongst people who correctly point out
that there are lots of folks who are in
a vulnerable position where anonymity is
the only way for them to reveal what
they know without harming their families
Etc I agree putting their jobs at risk
yep I also agree that there are
historical examples in which Anonymous
uh Publications
have persuaded people usefully so it I
think it's a trade-off and
I still think the net effect in the
present is spectacularly negative but
it's not a simple matter and so anyway
there's various versions of uh
pseudonymous
um
structures that might
free us from the worst and do do any of
them uh prevent the Arbiter like the the
holder of the information that verifies
that this is a real person from being
the social media company itself oh
that's a great question presumably you
could
set up a Contracting system where just
like
your vendor may not know your credit
card number because you've submitted a
tripe or something yes but the question
is okay then how do you build one of
those that you can trust yeah
um so anyway it's a
a complex and thorny issue and you've
got to figure out exactly which problem
you're trying to solve right are you
trying to just make sure
people don't have multiple accounts
that's a big deal you're trying to make
sure that each account is a real person
that's a big deal are you trying to make
sure that well things are traceable back
to an individual if they do something
terrible right so some version of
reputation but I mean also the first one
you came up with multiple accounts
especially I mean
this is both important and it feels so
ridiculous to be talking about it at all
but um it is important
and
um like I'd never been on social media
at all until Evergreen blew up and I got
an account and then it became really
clear uh that my same account without my
mental initial uh was going to be
grabbed by someone and was going to be
you know tagged as as my account because
it is my name right right so I think
your brother's suggestion actually
I got that account and just have you
know one thing at the top of it that
says you know my you know this is me but
my real account is is there and
you know if I couldn't have that second
account someone would have grabbed it
someone would be out there pretending to
be me especially so the reason that this
is you know even more fraught now is I
think that's what the blue check was
supposed to help with right and uh now
that a there's a lot of us who you know
could you are sometimes impersonated
um who still don't have the blue check
it's not very useful and also given that
now it's just a like a
I don't even know what it's supposed to
indicate anymore so there's basically
you went from a system that was deeply
flawed especially because there was so
much censorship on the inside to a
really there's no system at all
at least without checking a few yeah you
have to click a few things deep to
figure out some things yes the primary
function that it's serving and I think
it's a very low quality implementation
but the primary thing is it
sweeps away a huge fraction of the low
quality bot
um
many sock puppet architecture
right by putting a price that is
non-trivial on having an account you
can't make a thousand accounts to all
um you know rally around the same
[ __ ] cause and so anyway it clears
away a lot of noise it clears it away
with a lot of people who are for real so
I mean you've obviously been on the
inside of that and I haven't but it
feels to me like given what we know
about the amount of money
that is at stake and has changed hands
in some ways over the suppression of
true information yep uh uh in the last
several years
there's plenty of money out there to buy
tens of thousands of bots for any given
cause sure so it doesn't even feel to me
like it's the barrier that it seems like
it is well it's not even that simple
though because I think each account
needs to have a unique credit card and
so there's a it's just it puts a tax on
that behavior it's certainly not Beyond
powerful entities to use it but it
removes a huge fraction of it right yep
um
and by the way I do think it was not
done well and it should have been done
differently and it should be effectively
at least
that Twitter
uh evaluates your humanness
and allows you only one account now I
don't know what you do about that other
case it might be that you should be able
to say I want this account and I want
that account which is certain to become
a unique problem for me parked I don't
want to use it but I don't want anybody
else to use it but then again you know
uh does John Smith
have the same situation as how they're
hiring you know I don't know but
um
so something I think I think a much
better implementation would have been
good and you know musk is learning the
hard way that some of these things that
seem like Solutions cause big problems
yeah
um
on the same topic just a comment big
Tech and data privacy attorney here by
the way the ad Tech and data privacy
landscape is fascinating right now many
problems are spawning from digital
advertising
digital advertising that's oh it and
he's written a couple others
Kappa c-o-p-p-a
all caps and other laws do restrict data
collection and add activity towards
children that would be a fun discussion
um
all right yeah I would certainly like to
know that because it certainly looks
like there's an awful lot of advertising
that will reach children predictably
yeah exactly and then just one more uh
from the same the same person Heather
you hit the nail on the head about HR
it's truly shocking yeah I mean I think
HR is becoming Dei at some level yeah
and
a jobs program for um
Betty tyrants
Petty tyrants that's what it is
we need a
what's the what's the song in the Final
Cut the home for incurable tyrants yeah
yeah the Fletcher Memorial the Fletcher
Memorial Home for incurable tyrants and
kings
um Fletcher Memorial Home for incurable
Petty tyrants and would be Kings it's
gonna be rather larger than we have room
before
that's why we have Mars
oh is that what he's doing I don't know
but we'll see now it's the first thing
I've heard that sounds like a proper use
of that planet it's a penal colony okay
um
regarding Mouse telomeres do you have
any thoughts on the recent FDA
modernization act 2.0 no longer
requiring animal testing for new drugs
you see this I've just just barely ran
into this FDA has yeah and I don't I
don't know the limits I don't like but
something came out don't require animal
testing for new drugs yeah look I'm not
a fan of the animal testing on the other
hand I'm really not a fan of taking I'm
not testing it ones that have not been
tested yeah
um
yeah on the other hand uh
my slides the uh what what'd you say
um did you say my slides slice lie yeah
I'm trying to remember uh what the
there's a little syllogism uh about
I can't remember what it is but anyway
yes my sir even people who don't
understand the telomere issue understand
that mice give them results that are
deeply misleading yeah
yeah so I mean drug testing is animal
testing drug testing on animals is
fraught for a billion reasons we don't
need to do that on camera do we
um he's just cleaning his leg Yeah
um
yeah because the the mice lie the rodent
the rodent models lie in general
um the primates are it's cruel and
unusual at best
uh I don't know what what
I don't even know what other like those
those are the main clades of animal
models or bread not animal models of of
animals that get um drug safety tested
on
uh so yeah I don't
I don't know what the answer is though
well a fresh sheet of paper frankly I
don't trust I don't trust these people
and I don't trust that you can
um amend the system usefully and make it
work there are too many they're clearly
too many separate defects combining to
create a little Paradise for Pharma and
a Minefield for the rest of us yep
merch idea
big Pharma an ounce of prevention is
redacted text with red marker written
over it a breach of the fiduciary
responsibility to shareholders you know
I was thinking exactly that I guess I
hadn't gone as far as Mark but yes
that's screenshotting it yeah okay good
thank you
um
we've got we've got a number of things
that are just links and the way this
comes in I can't it's actually
complicated it's hard to click on links
so I don't know what's in them what can
you tell us about itching sometimes it's
positive sometimes delightful sometimes
deadly Ish what's up with that
itching itching yeah I've I've done
normal thinking in the neighborhood here
um
imagine that you had a creature like a
person for instance for example
and that that creature had you know a
surface area and that that surface area
really in the realm of sci-fi here man
now it's okay wild wild stuff but
stretch your mind right that's right
okay now imagine that that surface area
can be breached in all kinds of ways it
can be breached by little parasites that
will put a little appendage in and drink
lymph it can be breached by a spine from
a plant that can get into your skin and
it can cause an abrasion or a reaction
or all kinds of things right so the
point is there's really no shortage of
little ways that something can be off
about your skin
and suppose that you were a dexterous
creature that had
um you know fingers with nails and stuff
where you might be able to usefully do
something about some of that stuff right
well how are you going to detect it well
maybe what you do
is you detect
um
that
some cells that were in a state before
are now slightly pressing on each other
right that would happen if you got some
Thorn right or some tiny little you know
like hair like like a cactus you ever
touched one of those cactuses where the
little almost microscopic hairs yeah the
hairs get stuck in your skin right well
you might have a detector that would be
able to detect the fact that there's
just pressure because your cells are
slightly pushed apart by something or no
longer in contact with each other where
they were or something like that right
um
or you could have I mean imagine a
mosquito
has landed upon imagining a mosquito
yeah imagine a mosquito has landed on
you you know one of the few really great
things about January yes in general you
don't have to think about mosquitoes no
you don't at least here in the northern
hemisphere right but we're gonna and
then we'll stop because it's uh it's a
little irritating it's exactly the point
an irritation causes itchiness right so
but you think about how the mosquito
looks as it's like there's nothing more
annoying than that noise right but I
suppose it doesn't go by your ear oh in
the last three years I I can now think
of things more annoying than that noise
Fair Point yeah
um
to an ancestor there are a few things
more annoying than that noise of the
mosquito but if it doesn't pass as it is
with plasmodium falciprum right
malaria on board exactly yes um but the
legs of that animal are so exquisitely
built so that you do not detect the bulk
of that animal as it lands on your skin
because it's so well suspended right
yeah you can hear it uh it is not it is
not one the selection game to make it
inaudible well you can barely feel it
even more so I think that we have
enhanced detection that we've got like
if you would expect us to have an
amplifier on the skin as well and we do
and we do so the point is you would need
a very sensitive detector to feel one of
those legs just sitting on the surface
of your skin so lightly right or as it
uh takes its proboscis is it a proboscis
I don't know it takes it's a proboscis
or or whatever you call that in
mosquitoes and its needle nose begins to
insert it between your cells right those
things have to trigger something right
now here's the punch line of the joke is
okay if you've got that detector because
there are mosquitoes in the world and
they might be carrying malaria and so
you really need to know early like
before it gets its proboscis inserted
very deeply into your tissues that
something is on you then guess what now
you got a smoke detector problem right
if that smoke detector is going to save
your life then it's going to go off when
you burn toast right and so what you've
got is a system that is tuned to detect
something that could be a mosquito's leg
but you know what could be a mosquito's
leg just about anything right the
tiniest little fiber from a piece of
clothing that is in the wrong place and
buying you know it's
no one knows what you're talking about
nobody has ever experienced that tiny
little fiber that drives you crazy in
the back of the right so the point is
you've got a smoke detector problem but
there's no better way to build it great
analogy yeah yeah now that is a great
analogy and so still though
what we are left with is
um it's like allergies yeah right uh
where there's also kind of a smoke
detector problem in some ways uh but
some some itchiness
uh is really telling you to tend to
something you can work it out you can
you can like you can get the little
urdicating hairs off before they work
their way in right uh but but sometimes
there's maybe an inflammation below the
surface about which you can do nothing
or at least you can do nothing without
causing more damage than is already
going to happen
so so there's there's also that like the
question was
um sometimes it's positive sometimes
delightful so that's more about like the
perception because sometimes itchiness
does kind of feel like oh that's why
like oh
right and sometimes like I can't believe
this still itches I'm like I'm gonna
destroy myself scratching it right right
well so a you can imagine if you've got
detectors on your surface looking for a
mosquito-like phenomena or ticks or
whatever it is that they might alert you
to early and then you had an
inflammation underneath from for
whatever reason right that that
inflammation would be setting off
detectors in the neighborhood for all
kinds of reasons right
so the point is of course there would be
some itch and not because there's
something useful to do with the
inflammation just because those
detectors are not sophisticated they're
not like antibodies looking for a
particular electromagnetic signature
yeah anything that could be a mosquito
or anything else but the other thing is
the question about like I mean forgive
me for raising a gross subject implied
by this question
but something like picking a scab right
now obviously there is a degree to which
picking a scab is a negative thing in
many cases you can
you can cause an infection you can rip
the thing off and delay the healing on
the other hand there is almost certainly
a reason that at the point that some
wound has scabbed over and healed pretty
well and you pull that scab off and
you're back to what you were the relief
involved in finally pulling that damn
thing off is so great that and what what
precedes that moment in the healing
process is itching is itching right
exactly and what's more there's another
thing I mean imagine whatever the
hunter-gatherer version of Road rashes
right Road Rash being the thing that
happens when you fall off your bike or
your motorcycle or whatever I'm thinking
you'd Chase your Corey off the same edge
of the cliff that you were just trying
to chase it off of
yeah or you know you could imagine you
know you
slide on a rock and you've now got
little tiny pieces of gravel embedded in
you right and in some sense there's a
working cost benefit right cost benefits
so if you get the you know if the goo
that makes the the natural bandage for
you ends up encapsulating some little
Stone that's sitting there and then you
pull it out yeah you probably slowed
your healing a little but you didn't
really want to heal around that little
tiny piece of stone anyway and so yeah
you have some
um tendency to go after these things
because there's a value right and as you
point out stuff working stuff out is
worth damage if the other alternative is
it working its way in that's right right
because those things are particularly I
mean we have mechanisms to deal with
them right you get a little piece of
something in your tissue and your your
body will wall it off so it doesn't
interact with you physiologically but
that's a costly way to deal with that
it's costly I'm remembering I don't have
the research at my fingertips but um
there is some research being done
on frogs and we're trying to figure out
how to mark them and trust me this is
actually a phony issue it's like really
it's really it's really hard to Mark
frogs in a way that you can know when
you come back to one that it's the same
individual I resorted to tattooing them
yes you did and it worked ish decently
you're not not great in you know in the
field in Madagascar
um
but what these people had done and your
frogs are also small and so if you want
if you if you want to put something on
them so that you can track them remotely
um the batteries aren't going to last
very long because the animals themselves
are so small on you when the for Volant
animals it's like no more than 10 of the
weight of the animal it should be
something you add to it right something
like that for hippity hop animals maybe
a little more but whatever so they had
um they had encased it in something that
wasn't supposed to be um that the gut
wasn't supposed to respond to or or
evacuate I think either they they
force-fed these frogs these little
transponders or they may have actually
stitched them deep into the skin a
little RFID I think so yeah this is a
while ago and I should I should have
looked it up it was I used to talk about
this and I would lecture on marking
techniques for animals and um the study
keeps just losing the frogs and like wow
these frogs are really prone to dying
but then they started occasionally
finding the transponders or the RFID
whatever they are they're just kind of
lying around like well
what happened and so they took some of
these frogs I think into the lab which
is the opposite of the field
um
and and gave them these things however
they had given them to them in the first
place I think again
by mouth but I'm not positive about that
and their bodies
encased them
and moved them through tissue through
muscle out of their bodies and they
didn't come out the GI tract they didn't
they didn't come out they came out
through like whatever was closest like
probably you know as the side and you
know amphibians and and mammals are
quite different capable of quite
different things but uh but that's
extraordinary and our bodies do not
quite as good a job in in of that
particular thing but we do encapsulate
things and move them and you know expel
eventually now
we can infer the other part of that
story which is that those frogs went
back to their friends and were like I
got abducted somebody put a some kind of
a transmitter and I was hearing voices
and nobody believed him yeah they're
like
evidence where is it dude I got rid of
it I had to get rid of it they were
gonna keep following me like you said
paranoid
all right we must have been at it for
close to an hour at this point and we've
got so many more questions
I'm gonna just do a couple more really
quickly uh are you familiar with the
Venus Project sounds similar to Brett's
idea of game B
uh I have heard of it has not delved
deeply okay uh why does ankyloglossia
which is tongue tie exist in newborns
doesn't seem to make much sense much
love to you too
um tongue tie where the the uh whatever
it's called the the piece of tissue that
connects the tongue to the the floor of
the mouth
um it's really short in some newborns
and it gets in the way of their ability
to breastfeed
um I have not given this any thought at
all I had to actually I thought that's
what the word meant but I had to quickly
look it up before coming on that's
basically the extent of my knowledge of
it but my suspicion is uh that it's more
prevalent now yeah this is a hyper novel
thing and I don't I don't know what is
going on that's contributing to it but
the prediction is uh check out people
who aren't doing all the crazy hyper
modern stuff we're doing and see if uh
yeah and see if tongue tie isn't our
ankle iglossia isn't a lot less common
um
that's a long question uh what are your
thoughts on the works and opinions of
Alex Epstein Alex Epstein Bjorn lomborg
and Michael schellenberger thank you
um please let me do it really quick I
don't know who Epstein is I do okay
um let's put it this way I think there's
something to be learned in this
conversation and that um
we're gonna have to reboot everything
and you know how people will know from
my conversation with Michael
schellenberger that I quite like the guy
actually I was very suspicious of him at
first I still think he's dead wrong on
fission power
um but I mean we aren't we no longer
live in California but we were we both
thought he would have made an excellent
Governor well he would have made an
excellent Governor I think hopefully uh
we could have had a conversation about
the wisdom of nuclear power or Vision
power at that point
um he would definitely have made a
better Governor than Gavin Newsom but
then again so what a rotten eggplant and
um you know that's no reflection on on
Michael yeah
no not at all
um I don't know this one either what do
you think of the open letter from the
Vandenberg coalition to the Lancet media
Etc condemning the suppression of the
lab League Theory
I don't know the letter uh I don't think
I know the letter I'm guessing I'm in
favor of the letter and uh would wag my
finger at the Lancet for all of the
reasons that people know yeah
okay
uh
two more questions
do you think Canada will become as
dystopian as the former Soviet Russia
trying to decide when to get my family
out of here
I'm afraid
you know we know and know of many people
who are considering leaving Canada which
they view as their absolute home
uh you know our Canadians through and
through
uh I am not as tuned in to what's going
on right now as I was about a year ago
and I stayed tuned in for a while after
the after the truckers Convoy
um but
ah
I fear I'm being naive somehow still and
it feels like Canada really on the other
hand why not like all the evidence
points to they're not making sense
and they're willing to take away so many
so many freedoms
and uh and threaten
so many barriers to Freedom
yep
um
I will say I'm a little bit
uh hesitant
to give you an opinion on whether or not
I think that's plausible because
um
I believe the most important thing is if
you if your spidey sense is telling you
that that's where you're headed and
anybody says oh I don't think it's going
to go that way and that persuades you to
relax then you may be putting yourself
in danger and you probably know more
about it than I do but so anyway what I
would say is
I don't know that that's where we are in
history I certainly do know that that
fella who is uh your prime minister
um has those inclinations and
uh unchecked I have little doubt that
that's where you would end up and
precious little self-awareness
like those inclined authoritarian
inclinations and no apparent
self-awareness of the impact
um and the inconsistency of his
being you know he's um he's a little bit
like
uh
Joffrey character who has grown up in
such a way that he from Game of Thrones
yeah that he can hide it right the the
Delight in torturing people is a little
bit better hidden but I do have the
sense that this is a person given what
he's done and how little remorse he has
about it and how clearly he's willing to
lie into a camera
um all of those things how excited he is
for photo ops yeah that this is this is
a machine and I don't know you know I
can't there's obviously a complex story
to be told about people who behave so
diabolically with respect to strangers
that doesn't inherently mean that he's
diabolical at home those two things you
know being a
decent family person in a diabolical
leader is not unheard of but I can say
that his public facing persona
could hardly be more alarming and the
fact that it comes in a pretty package
is even worse right
um so I would say that object alone
couldn't be more dangerous
as for your system
as for the inclinations of Canadians
maybe that protects you but
I don't know you know the question is
going to give a lot of us hope right
yeah with free psych of that reason like
they're
True North strong and free right yeah uh
but uh it's been a long time and
and it's an it's an arms race and
obviously the trucker Convoy was a
hugely hopeful thing but it's not like
um the Canadian version of Goliath
didn't learn a few things from it right
I sure did yeah
one last question it's a big one we're
going to take it briefly but it but we
know this is a big question
what is your opinion on antidepressants
I'm advised to take them but reluctant
because of fear to lose creativity and
numb my perception
we know nothing about your situation
right and uh
um
there are conditions under which they
seem to be some of the antidepressants
on the market now seem to be the right
thing for people uh at sort of at the
end of trying all of the less invasive
things
to deal with depression
but I would say like so much of what is
passing from Medical Care that actually
involves something that seems simple
because all you have to do is take a
pill
this is this should be a last resort
it's actually it's actually going to
have much longer term and complicated
and complex
side effects that go far beyond what the
medical system will likely alert you to
and trying to get your sort of your you
know the house that is your body in
order and the house that is your house
in order and your you know your
relations with other people
first it's a lot harder yeah sleep but
the house that is your body involves
um diet sleep and exercise and you know
get getting outside
you know preferably early every day and
moving your body around in nature and
you know following Michael paulin's
instructions and if you if you are
getting all of your food from a
supermarket buying at the edges and if
you are you know if you're foraging or
growing or hunting more power to you but
you know get the seed oils and the
sugars and all the synthetic stuff uh
out of your out of your diet and move
your body a lot and spend time outside
and
um and get rid of as much of the
extraneous
novelty in your life as you can with
regard to sleep
you know go to bed at a regular time and
make sure you're not looking at screens
for some hour or hours before that and
get the noise and the light and
hopefully all the electromagnetic
radiation out of your room and uh and
sleep simply and you know don't take
other work to bed with you like all the
things that lots of people are saying
but uh
there's a lot of things to be done
and almost all of them are more
complicated than taking a pill but
if they don't work you can stop doing
them and no harm no foul yeah whereas if
you stop taking antidepressant sometimes
still your body will be reacting to
having taken that for a long time to
come
so I would add a couple of things one
the whole antidepressant thing
is the result of a bad model of how
psychology works
um chemical imbalance Theory which was
nonsense and it was transparently
evolutionary nonsense which is not to
say that nobody's ever had a chemical
imbalance but the idea that some huge
fraction of the population has a
chemical imbalance and that the
explanation for that chemical imbalance
is not exogenous obesity is biological
it's it's the same air it's that same
nonsense that said
um
it is you have to be aware of something
a there's a distinction between the
short-term consequence of taking
whatever it is you're contemplating
taking and the long-term implications it
is not unlikely that in the short term
anything that disrupt disrupts normal
will create novelty novelty and Intrigue
in your life
right like taking any drug
and so the point is okay so then if you
say well
my my doctor tells me that this is going
to help I don't know and then you take
it it's like oh
that's interesting
kind of like it yeah I feel different I
feel better good yeah but then but four
weeks later like oh I don't feel better
anymore oh well we got you know we
didn't have the dosage right right and
then the point you make is now if you
take it away hmm crash right and to the
point well not just that but actually
you know chemical After Effects as well
that's what I mean but the point is now
your body has equilibrated to it you're
not getting anything for it you're
paying whatever consequences there is
for having to process this uh novel
compound and if you take it away now the
point is you have the opposite effect
that you had at the beginning uh which
was the novelty of its presence so
there's a lot of danger in this stuff
um I am a huge fan of the following idea
as I know you are that
a human being is designed to function
sometimes you can't function because
something developmentally disrupted you
and you've lost whatever it was that
would allow you to function normally and
then you need a corrective lens of some
kind like maybe even a physically
corrective lens to deal with your
misshapen eyes or whatever right but in
other cases
sorry about that that was a little
personal but in other cases
there's something that's messing you up
that actually if you could find it and
eliminate it you'd be better now I don't
know maybe depression
is more often than not the result of a
long-standing pattern of psychology
where you get into a a rut and there's
not something in your current
environment that is responsible for it
but the number of times that I've found
something in my life that actually was
making me unhealthy in some way and
didn't know it right is large right
these things are there and it takes a
sort of diligence about looking at
patterns
and noticing yeah that thing shows up
and I wonder what happens if I remove it
from my life yep and this and this is
one reason that you know missing from my
already very abbreviated but very long
list of things that you can do
um travel like if if you are
sometimes lucky sometimes not lucky
enough to be working remotely where you
can actually take your job on the road
uh and and you are in Blackness like you
cannot Escape enough that your doctor is
saying really you should try these
antidepressants because I don't know
what to do for you
um if
granted that that is that is a very
difficult moment at which to figure out
how to get yourself someplace totally
new but if you can get yourself
someplace totally new with the
expectation of you know and if you have
the luxury and the freedom to say
actually I can continue doing my work
but in a place
somewhere totally else for three months
that's going to bring a whole lot of
things into Focus because you're going
to now recognize uh what you don't have
what you do have that you want what you
you know are missing what you're not
missing it just it reveals a whole lot
of things and you you can do that on a
smaller scale you can
you know you can even just like change
up where the furniture is in your house
so that when you're walking through it
at you know at night when you can't
sleep because you know our or maybe
you're sleeping too much but then you do
get up and like oh
right the couch is over there now
just giving yourself a regular like oh
okay this is not
this is not the same darkness that I've
been living through this is this is
something different and you know it it
may be in the end that that drug is what
you need um but
I wouldn't start there yep
um I would also say that there may be
some uh
somewhat extreme novel interventions
that don't have the same implication as
a pharmaceutical
um I know that all four of us in this
family sorry Fairfax not talking about
you have been experimenting with
um
cold water plunges showers stuff like
that and uh that's amazing well it's a
little uncomfortable while you're doing
it but it does seem to create I find
that it's exhilarating it is
exhilarating yes I prefer the
exhilaration of the cold shower when
you're in the hot Amazon and it is a
respite
yeah it's cold enough but so our
favorite one of our favorite places on
Earth is tipatini this field station in
the middle of the Ecuador and Amazon
very very remote ex like one maybe the
most biodiverse spot on earth and the
there's no heated water
um but there's abundant water
because they're just pulling water from
the Rio tipatini which is a tributary of
the Napa which is tributary of the
Amazon uh and and it's endless because
the river's flowing right by uh
and somehow even in the Amazon when you
get under it you're like oh wow it's
cold but I think now now you're you're
prepared yeah but anyway something like
that you know uh a a cold whatever shock
to the body
um a has health benefits real ones
um B uh some of the benefits are that it
psychologically takes you into a very
different state and you do have this
kind of euphoria
um at least after it yeah
um that you know is somewhat lasting now
I've done less with this than you have
but sauna also known to have benefits
breaks up your day so it's not the same
monotony as you were pointing out so
anyway the question is is there
something that you could introduce to
your life sauna most people don't have
access to sauna we moved to an island
where we don't have access to a sauna
for instance but um many people have
access you know the water coming out of
our TAPS in our showers is
and the water coming out of say the tap
in an apartment in Seattle is not nearly
as cold apparently uh but uh still
everyone has access to coldish water
even if you don't have a plunge pool or
you know really really cold water and
you don't have access to sauna everyone
has access to you know turn it to cold
brace yourself walk in and
um you know it's cool if you're in a
place where you're allowed to yell a
little bit but yep
definitely definitely good but uh anyway
uh breaking whatever pattern you know if
you're stuck in an Eddy What You Need Is
A disruption something interesting
something novel
and that pill could maybe provide you
some of that but certainly worth
checking whether there's something
healthier that might might do the trick
yep totally okay well even my computer
has given up at this point is that
you've been going on for too long not
you no I have but no it doesn't it
wasn't yeah it wasn't specified
it probably does it probably does uh
that was a that was long uh we will be
back next week same time
same place
same bat channel
here we go yeah it is all good and it is
all good I've noticed that
[Music]
why given that I said that would you
believe anything else that I say
I have always not liked that phrase I
people people said that back when it
seemed like you could plausibly believe
that it was all good and so I was like
no it's not you know that it's all good
does suggest very low standards
um yeah how do you feel about my bad
oh diving we use we use that because of
ultimate yes right but I actually quite
like it you know it properly relieves
somebody oh absolutely thought that they
might have been responsible for
something yeah no that was me yeah yeah
totally all right um oh this was our bad
until we see you next be good to the
ones you love eat good food
outside be well everyone
foreign
[Music]